Let's go to the phones for the absolute last
final time of twenty twenty on discord at David
Pakman dotcom slash discord. Let's first go to
Kate in Ohio. Kate in Ohio, what is going on?
Not much. David, how are you doing?
I'm doing well. Cool.
So do I ask your question, that would
be a great next step. Yeah, let's do it.
So do you think it's politically
important to eventually abolish
the Electoral College as really
it's the only way Republicans can
win the elections nowadays as their ideas
are generally becoming less popular?
Yes, I do. I do think so. And we've talked before
about the paths to doing it. I don't I don't
really see any path. You can never say never.
I don't see any path any time soon to doing it
via constitutional amendment because there are so
many red states that know that their candidates
have won solely because we have an electoral
college system instead of a popular vote system.
So if it's going to happen even relatively soon,
I believe it would be through something like the
National Popular Vote, Interstate Compact and
Peevski. I've talked about that before. But yes,
I think if the now it is true what Republicans
say, that if we had a national popular vote,
they would run elections
differently. And Trump has said that.
But regardless, I think it would be a massive
uphill battle for the Republican Party to climb.
OK, cool.
All right, thanks very much, Kate, I appreciate
it. Great to hear from Kate from Ohio.